Japanese Advice
No. 10 What time can you say good morning? That's a good question. How much do
you care about other people's eyes
?  Do you think
that Americans will change their
minds? I think there will probably be a lot of Americans saying that they can't do
it.At least I'm sure
it will.
Or should I just
pay the money and have the city dispose of it
?
Please tell me the expression on your face when
you pretend to be okay.
But when
I tried to say that next time, he was
laughed at, isn't he Japanese?
If I say that, most of the Japanese people will probably
hear that, and that's
wrong.It's
not summer,
it's not
summer.  Or is
it summer?
Japanese people
don't know how to teach this sort of thing, which is why
I created the pay chair series, but
Natsushi hasn't scored yet
either.
No,
girl,
girl, girl
How do you say I message in Japanese?
I forget the katakana of my name so
often  I think it's best not to ask people
, but eventually most of the nouns in Japanese
will become foreign words in katakana,
so I think I'll naturally be able to read them quickly.I want to
see anime that uses only foreign words soon.
I don't want to see It
's hard to memorize intransitive and transitive verbs, isn't it
?  I've been studying a lot, but I
've forgotten about half of
it The good news is that the
only time I have to write kanji is when I'm taking Japanese classes, right
?  Instead
watch Cyberpunk Edgerunners and learn some Japanese slang I think most
languages ​​are like that but
when you're having a conversation in Japanese in Japanese
you can understand what the other person is saying but it's
hard to be yourself
Do you have any advice that I can't convey
what I want to
say?  It's
not always possible to explain fluently and neatly like this, so
well, especially
about the differences between Western and Western philosophies.
What was the most difficult part of the grammar? What was the most difficult thing?
I do a lot and my
grammar is perfect, but my
pronunciation seems to be the worst.
For example
, if you suddenly change to the Kansai dialect while using standard Japanese, it will be considered strange.
Well, to be honest
, if you want to be seen as smart, to some extent
, I think it's safest to study Japanese accent and pronunciation and master the standard.  Yeah, but
if you want to be told you're good at it